one thing that really surprised me
actually when we figured this out is
that energy just corresponds to
essentially the density of activity in
the hypergraph and then what happens is
for example gravity works by when when
you think about how things move in space
and by the way okay what what are things
so a particle for example in this setup
a particle like an electron is a kind of
a a persistent structure that persists
under a lot of rewritings it's similar
to in a fluid like water or something
you have a Vortex which is made of lots
of different molecules all sort of
spinning around in some coherent way
that's it's the same kind of story with
with this hypograph that something like
an electron is a persistent structure
that exists in this hypograph and the
fact that motion is possible is not
obvious the fact that it's possible to
take a thing like an electron and have
it move without change or without a
percept but without a perceived change
is not an obvious thing it's something
you have to establish but any case the
when when you can kind of think of uh
sort of a simple version of motion it's
just taking shortest distances in the
hypergraph and it turns out that then
the uh the uh what energy activity in
the hypergraph does is to deflect those
shortest paths and that process turns
out to be exactly what you get in
gravity according to the Einstein
equations and so on so it's pretty neat
that one can start from nothing one just
starting from this this hypergraph and
these rules on this hypergraph and you
can derive general relativity you can
derive the structure of space-time
so
you can actually go on and one of the
other things is that I said you know you
do these rewrites on this hypograph well
any given there are many different ways
that these rewrites could be done so
they're actually many different parts of
history that could be followed it's
depending on which order you do these
particular rewrites in well it turns out
that then you get this thing we call a
multi-way graph which is a graph that
represents all these possible histories
sometimes the sometimes the histories
will will Branch sometimes they'll merge
because two things will end up being in
the same state end up evolving to the
same state okay so you have this giant
branching merging structure that
represents the the sequence of all
possible histories for the universe
effectively well it turns out that the
that gives you quantum mechanics it's
it's an inevitable feature of our models
that you get quantum mechanics and since
the the fundamental difference between
classical mechanics and classical
mechanics you know you throw a ball it
goes in a definite trajectory quantum
mechanics you follow many different
possible trajectories and you get to say
things about only what the probabilities
of different outcomes are so in this
case what's happening is you have this
completed deterministic model that
generates this multi-way graph and the
multi-way graph then
uh is the the the thing that represents
quantum mechanics so you just as if you
take a slice across this multi white
graph the multi-way graph can be thought
of as evolving in time
um and you can take a slice at a fixed
time and you get this whole collection
of of essentially Quantum States and you
have this map we call it a branchial
graph a map of of the entanglements
between Quantum branches and it turns
out that that we take the limit of that
you get something which is not physical
space it's another kind of space we call
it branchial space which is a kind of
space of quantum States and just as you
can have the Einstein equations and you
derive in the Continuum limits you
derive the Einstein equations for
physical space the corresponding
equations that you derive in branchial
space are the Fineman path integral so
you derive the fundamental equations of
quantum mechanics so this is a pretty
neat thing that you've started from just
this underlying in a sense nothing
underneath you one has always assumed
that you know things like relativity
quantum mechanics and so on were kind of
Wheeling features of our universe that
you had to just say the universe happens
to have these particular rules well what
what we'll see is that it's actually
inevitable that it has these rules okay
just okay now we get to the next and
this is a this is a complicated
conceptual stack and I'm trying to make
it as as uh as digestible as possible
here but but um okay so the next issue
is uh I should have ex well the next
issue has to do with how observers
interact with this whole the whole thing
because what's happening is the Observer
is part of the system this is supposed
to be a model for the whole universe and
for example the emergence of things like
special relativity depend on the fact
that the Observer is part of the system
but um
one of the features of the Observer is
that
okay the the underneath there's all this
complicated computationally irreducible
stuff going on but we as observers do
not sense that we are computationally
bounded Observers
Let me Give an example which actually in
in 20th century physics there were
basically three big theories general
relativity quantum mechanics and
statistical mechanics and the second law
of thermodynamics
um it turns out all three of those
theories came come from the exact same
conceptual Foundation they are in some
sense the same Theory
um in the second law of Thermodynamics
what you're interested in knowing is
given that you have a bunch of uh
molecules bouncing around you you have
this idea that that they'll tend to get
more random in their configurations and
all will in the end observe is things
like the gas laws and maximum entropy
States and and things like this well the
question is why do we observe that and
the answer is underneath all these
molecules are bouncing around and
they're they're doing things in a
computationally irreducible way but when
we get to make observations we are
computationally bounded we can only make
certain kinds of observations in as a
practical matter we might only make
observations that are on scales large
compared to the individual molecules but
the important conceptual point is that
we're always making computationally
bounded observations and in in the
theory of of statistical Annex one of
the Hundred Year confusions has been
about how you decide how you set up
initial States and so on and how you
don't end up with things where the
molecules are all arranged in just such
a way that at some moment all the
molecules will go over to one side of
the of the room
um that that is not observed to happen
is a consequence of the fact that the
initial conditions are also set up in
computationally bounded ways so
essentially the the the the second world
of thermodynamics is a consequence of
the interplay between us as
computationally bounded observers and
the underlying computational
irreducibility of all these molecular
dynamics that are going on well it turns
out that the you can see both relativity
and quantum mechanics as being
consequences of the same thing
underlying computationally reducibility
combined with us as observers being
computationally bounded actually we need
one other property the other property we
need is that we believe that we are
persistent in time now I sort of
explained that we are made of of the
same stuff that everything else in the
universe is made out of and it's not
obvious that we will be persistent in
time because at every moment we are made
from different atoms of space yet we
have the perception that we have a
single thread of experience we have we
are we have the perception that we're
persistent in time those two features
computational boundedness and belief
that we are persistent in time are
exactly what you need to derive general
relativity quantum mechanics and
statistical mechanics so that that I
consider to be a very very neat thing
that um uh sort of from from those
foundations you get that okay so let's
go to one more level of uh sort of um uh
I don't know conceptual sophistication
and then we'll then we'll perhaps be
able to come down and talk about some
some AI kinds of things in a in a
reasonable way the the next level is
this so I said okay we have this this
hypergraph it's being Rewritten
according to certain rules and maybe we
say here's a rule and this rule gives us
our universe okay that's a very weird
thing to be able to say because you'd
say why did we get this rule why didn't
we get another rule you know from
Copernicus on down so to speak
we've had this idea that there's nothing
sort of fundamentally special about our
us and our universe and so on
you just watched a clip from the
theories of everything channel for the
full video and all its magnificence then
click here and if you'd like to see more
then subscribe enjoy